Film Courage: How does a screenwriter know
when it’s time to sell their screenplay?
Daniel Calvisi, screenwriter: Well you want
to show it to a bunch of friends.
You want to get notes from friends who know
screenwriting, who know movies and know how
to give notes on a script.
So ideally you’re in a writer’s group
and you’ve got feedback from your writer’s
group.
You’ve written (I would say) at least five
or six drafts.
Writing it re-writing as we know.
And hopefully maybe you’ve shown it to someone
you’ve known in the industry, not as a submission
but as a friend to read, where they’ve given
you some feedback.
So there’s really no way to know exactly
when you’re going to be ready to bring something
to market but basically field-test it with
as many people as you can to the point where
you feel like it’s in its best shape as
possible.
Film Courage: Okay, let’s suppose friends,
family say “Oh this is excellent!”
Now we know that they have their reasons for
saying this, as well.
They don’t want to hurt our feelings.
They want to see us do well.
Let’s suppose we’re ready to try and go
out there and take it to market, what are
some of the of the first things, what are
some websites that we can go to, what can
we do to try and help sell it?
Daniel: I think you should make a hit list
of companies and people that you’re going
to send your script to.
First of all, it’s good to get a rep.
So you want to send it to managers that accept
unsolicited submissions.
I believe The Writer’s Guild has a list
of those.
There’s a website called The Tracking Board
where you can probably find some good manager
lists.
But I always say pick up the phone.
That’s the big thing now.
We don’t make as many phone calls as we
used to.
It makes us all a little nervous and if you’re
a skittish writer who is more of an introvert
that’s tough.
But you have to pick up the phone and you
can actually get submissions just from cold-calling
and introducing yourself and being nice and
saying “Hey, here is what my script is about,
here is the log line, do you want to read
it?”
Now they may shut you down right away and
say “We don’t accept any unsolicited submissions”
but they may love it and they can send you
a waiver form that you can sign where you
can submit without a rep.
But that’s only if they’ve heard your
log line, they’ve heard your pitch and they
really like it and they want to read it.